I'm afraid the World Health Organization
is unreformable I don't think and
there's no there's clearly no will
within the organization to to reform it
it is more or less been trolling the
world since covid by doing things like
appointing North Korea and coming up all
these ridiculous announcements um it
seems to me they almost want to be
closed down we can't close them down we
shouldn't close them down overnight
obviously but I think the idea of
setting up some rival organization which
will eventually out compete the who with
pandemic preparedness I think that's
probably the way forward and if people
like Bill Gates and less likely Mike
Bloomberg put their money into that kind
of thing that that's a very real
possibility and that could happen in a
relatively short period of time without
any disruption I would say